i have some students in the northwest
valley are learning an important lesson
ahead of thanksgiving
they are collecting food to make
thanksgiving special for families in
need
look at these students here they are
from mountain view lutheran school
there they are they went door-to-door
yesterday morning for their annual
thanksgiving scavenger hunt
they left empty bags on doorsteps for
people to fill with food
this year they are collecting the
fixings things like canned yams
vegetables and box stuffing
and all the donations are going to
lutheran social services of nevada
service and helping the community is
does not start when you get to a certain
age it does not start when
you can get to a certain point in life
it starts the moment you're able to open
your eyes and
see there's a need i can fill it those
students will collect the bags
on thursday hopefully filled with food
it's also a friendly competition among
the preschoolers and the elementary
school students look at that cute kid
if you'd like to help there's a box to
donate just outside the school if you
don't live in the area and got a bag on
your doorstep
you can just drop off food on cheyenne
off north grand canyon
and what a great lesson they're teaching
those kids it's now their fourth year
they usually do
pies and frozen turkeys too but they're
not doing that this year because of
kovitz
so you can still help and isn't that
adorable yeah and lutheran social
services uh they do great work i've
actually did a story a couple of years
ago there at their food bank and what
they do
to try and help the community over on
boulder highway so good organization
here in town and
if you see a bag on your door now you
know why there you go
that's awesome especially with the k
making sure younger kids understand
what thanksgiving is really all about
yeah and i'm glad they're still doing it
because of course that would be
something they will be doing
in schools and having their box and
putting bringing in canned food so
the fact that they're still able to find
ways to do that awesome
good stuff yeah